hey everybody welcome back see ya girl
horn I've had some fun with three shade
and a link a tutorial in the description
made by variable gaming on how to get it
to work but basically it allows you to
do all kinds of post effects in game so
all of the shots that you're looking at
right now have some ambient occlusion
and depth of field effects as well as
just general nice looking stuff like a
Myint lighting and things like that
attached to them so yeah that's why the
game looks really different than normal
and why the autofocus is being a bit
weird as the train just passed by right
there but yeah I've been super excited
about this primarily because I want to
use this info whare but you'll see more
of that later on
but yeah I've just had some fun going
around the map of Jaeger horn and trying
out all of the effects and I think it
just works really well on this map
anyway let's get started on the build of
today and very quickly there I actually
kind of accidentally showed in the
time-lapse some pre-built stuff that I
had just kind of measuring out what I
wanted to build here and usually I don't
really show that stuff but I figured I
might as well leave that in there
basically before I build I very often
just build up they just kind of draw out
the shape of what I want to build in
very basic pieces so that I have an idea
of what things are gonna look like just
to you know make sense of size and
shapes and composition of everything
before I get into the actual detailing
that set the actual detailing of the
building is what I'll be getting into
for the rest of this episode and yes it
will only be one building I was hoping
to maybe do a little bit more than this
but by the time I was done with this I
already figured I had enough footage to
just make one episode out of it so
that's that I'll get to the surrounding
area in the next episode most likely so
what I wanted to build is something that
I've been struggling with for a long
time this piece of land has been
demarcated as parts of the park to build
a building on for a really long time I
just really couldn't figure out what I
wanted to do with this I wanted to turn
it into a restaurant or some kind of
food servers
I really couldn't figure out how to fit
it into the rest of the place I've been
procrastinating on this for pretty much
the entire duration of the build which
is over a year already I'm ashamed to
admit so I finally decided that it was
time to get to this piece of land and
before I did I just kind of read it some
of the path layouts because I think this
works out a little bit better just being
one simple small building and yeah this
building itself is really going to sort
of be the weenie of this area that the
main drawer of attention even though
it's not going to draw that much
attention to it and something that I
think should close off this part of the
park quite neatly now my inspiration
came not from the Alps this time around
but actually from London there's this
really interesting villa called the
Chalet estate in London right next to
the team's actually I should say the
Thames I'm sorry I'm sorry all of you
Londoners I always referred back to when
I originally kind of thought it was
anyway yeah it's it's this really cool
estate which has an old Swiss Chalet on
it which supposedly was imported from
Switzerland in the 19th century and put
into London as a boathouse and a few
years ago some architect decided to pick
this up as it was kind of more or less
abandoned and turned it into what it is
right now which is quite a villa with
some extra floors as far as I know and
the result is this really interesting
build which is a very clear small Swiss
Chalet but placed on almost the pedestal
of multiple different floors underneath
it now the villa in real life would cost
you something like 10 million pounds or
upwards of that extremely expensive so
definitely not much of an idea to
emulate for a theme park I suppose but
on a smaller scale and with less floors
I thought it would be nice to build
something very similar just to get
something which looks unique and sets
itself apart from
the rest of the buildings in the park
enough to kind of seem like its own
little weenie very much like the station
building or the church building on top
of the the rock do because I do want to
have some more traditional simple rustic
buildings next to this but I really
wanted this building itself to draw some
attention to it and to kind of stand out
well at the same time having the same
general theme as the buildings around it
and that villa being you know a
traditional original Swiss Chalet but on
steroids basically served as a good
inspiration for that and I really like
the idea of having multiple floors as
well even though it almost starts
looking like an Asian pagoda in a sense
the villa that I'm talking about has
four floors one of them being the bottom
floor which is a little bit larger than
the other ones but the other ones are
pretty much just stacked floors like a
Japanese pagoda which is really
interesting to see so I'm gonna go with
one floor or less just to make the whole
building a little bit smaller and more
likely to be built in a theme park I
also think it just works a bit better
because if this building were really big
it would just kind of make it too
obvious that the the mountain
quote-unquote that the coaster itself is
based on is is really small and I should
also add of course I'm adding quite a
bit of forced perspective in this
building so this this shape I think
lends itself really well to having
forced perspective because the second
floor is already kind of set back from
the ground floor and then the top floor
with the roof over it which I'm going to
work on in a little bit it's gonna be
even smaller and even shorter so even
though all of the floor is kind of look
as if they are realistic and or about
the same size the top floor is getting
really small and
quite cramped which works really well
for their first perspective I think this
building overall really looks like it is
a proper three floor building even
though in terms of heights it's about
two and a little bit now most of it so
far and I'm sorry that I didn't talk
much about the detailing I probably
should have done that but this building
just kind of required a long intro I
suppose the rest of the detailing is
very similar to what I based it on in
real life which is almost a little bit
too copied for my liking I always like
to make the buildings that I come up
with you know even if they're inspired
by real-life buildings a bit more unique
than that but in this case I figured I
might as well just take it this way
because it's pretty much a winning team
that I don't want to change too much
some of the biggest changes include just
taking a floor out of it doing different
detailing elements because obviously we
have different pieces in planet coaster
than in real life and I really wanted to
make use of that and just come up with
new details and the the ground floor is
actually asymmetrical which is different
from the one in real life as well I just
like it this way because I like
asymmetry and I think it fits a little
bit better in this context to sort of
have an overhang on the side of the
coaster and on the side of this really
small valley that it's situated at but
not have the same kind of overhang on
the side of the path on the on the right
here I just thought that worked out a
little bit better composition wise and
then some of the other details are a bit
different as well I suppose in real life
the villa has a lot of glass on the
outside it's really quite modernized so
this one just has more wood and while it
does have some glass especially on these
sections here in the middle it's not
quite as much as the real knife
counterpart but yeah altogether I think
it just works too well to try and come
up with anything else to complicate it
too much and really if you take away the
ground floor of this build if you just
look at the the top two floors it is
pretty much just a simple traditional
style switch
all that really makes it different is
that it's based and is that it's built
on top of this this extra ground floor
which I think just works really well in
this context so yeah here's the top
floor where as you can see especially on
the supports of the roofs on the sides
this floor doesn't really actually make
much sense it's it's very small and it's
very very low but from a force
perspective sense I think it works quite
well and then for some of the other roof
decorations I'm just getting back to
this style which I have in the rest of
the build the Swiss Chalet style
inspired gable decorations and wooden
supports that support the roof I just
really loved that kind of detailing
underneath these roof structures of
these buildings which when I'm referring
to Swiss Chalet style in that case I'm
referring to the architectural style and
not to the building itself being a Swiss
Chalet so that's pretty much it for the
building itself so besides that I wanted
to have just a small Terrace underneath
this overhang here to put some picnic
tables and umbrellas and things like
that to make it look a little bit more
inviting it's not too much to this to be
honest just a quick simple defense over
here to demarcate that and make sure
that people aren't going to run until
you onto the coaster track and that's
really just about it I also need to get
back into some of the other sections of
the park here and add some elements in
which we didn't have before but I think
work out really well and one of those is
just the planters the extra planters
that we've gotten and some of the latest
updates are just so good especially the
empty ones like the the larger balls
that I just placed which are just great
because you can put your own flowers in
them which you know adds a whole lot a
whole nother layer of customization but
just because there is so large and you
can put them anywhere as extra
decoration to get some color into the
build I think it works out really well
this this whole build in general it's
all very rustic and just uses a lot of
gray and brownish colors and not too
much variation in terms of textures
because that's just realistically what
the theme would be like so having
flowers there is just one of the few
ways in which you can actually add some
color in this not to mention that I
think given the theme it's also quite a
must to have lots of flowers everywhere
for that sort of summer Alpine theme now
for the inside you might know that I am
terrible at indoor decorations so I'm
just putting some simple stalls there
some simple counters with very basic
decorations but that's really just about
it this is where the different
placements of the glass sections of the
building worked out really well though
because in the middle there are just
wooden panels on the sides of the
building so in those wooden panels I
could hide these shops might get back
into this later to give it some more
decoration I don't know what it is but I
just don't really like doing interiors
so I just like to keep them really
simple and just get it over with but one
day I should probably actually properly
do some interiors because throughout all
of the parks that I've done I've never
really delved into interior as much and
this is not going to be the exception
at least it's gonna be decently
functional and it's gonna be another
place for guests to actually get food
because so far I think the only actual
food places are all in the quote unquote
main street's area of the park with a
little fry shop and a few stalls in some
of the buildings kind of hidden on the
sides of the pocket and I guess there's
the the gift shop also next to the
coaster itself and in fact the rest of
this episode now is just going to
revolve around foliage because I'll be
adding so much foliage around this
building and even on the different
floors of this building which can always
feel very cheap I've said many times at
this point I think how foliage is often
for architecture just a way to try to
fix up
architecture or make make it look good
somehow which always kind of works if
you're not happy with the building just
throw some foliage around it and
eventually it's gonna end up looking
pretty good but in this case it just
fits the theme too well so please excuse
me here if I'm putting lots of flowers
and everything around this building or
flowers that are really just kind of
acting as bushes because still one of my
favorite things is just that we have
these flowers that we can recolor make
green I just use as bushes instead which
is something that I haven't done too
much throughout Diego horn because for
the majority of the build they weren't
in the game yet but I definitely also
want to get back into some of the other
parts and add some of those extra bushes
in just because I want all of the
foliage in this Park to look quite dark
and Alpine like and there was only a
very limited amount of foliage we had
when I started this that sort of fit
those descriptions but there's a lot
more of it now and then of course also
here on what are pretty much the
balconies of this building lots of red
flowers because that's what you
typically tend to see on these kinds of
buildings it just gets the the whole
vibe of this theme across best I think
and for the rest I'm just filling it up
with a lot of clutter because that works
out quite well to fill up empty spaces
just one of those very the theme park
ish the things I feel and one of the
reasons why in general you know whenever
I get the question of whether I'm
related to architecture in any way I
always kind of talk about that because
architecture in theme parks is just such
a completely different thing from
architecture in real life and then again
real life theme parks and designing real
life theme parks is a completely
different thing from just playing a
simulation game as well so yeah really I
I think I'm okay doing all of this stuff
just because we're in a theme park game
here which is very different from the
real world of architecture
and finally just dressing up this area a
little bit because I had to remove some
of the trees to actually keep the view
of the building because it wasn't
thinking of how the building was going
to be but given that the building is
quite small I want to have very few
trees around it to not try to dwarf the
building itself too much and allowed the
building to seem a little bit bigger
than it actually is
and yeah that's basically it for this
episode so I hope you guys enjoyed the
sort of comeback of Jaeger horn for now
I do want to get the next episode in
much quicker than the last time but yeah
I have to say I was very unmotivated and
uninspired for this project for a while
and then it was really hard to get
working on stuff but with this build
I've sort of regained some of my
inspiration there so hopefully I should
be on a good strike again anyway I'll
see you guys next episode
[Music]
you
[Music]